efectivamente yo estuve por sencillos de
dios puedo decir en las torres de velas
en el año y había significado para
realizar incluso de centros de bomberos
en hyeres mi viaje el día es el día 10
para tomar el curso en vista de la
hipótesis que se manejó inicialmente de
un accidente aéreo
me presento en las tornas en la 'zona
cero' invitado por los bomberos
para tratar de unirme al grupo de
primera respuesta tienes un convicto y
va a estar en las torres gemelas por el
supuesto accidente aéreo
lo que puede observar desde el comienzo
el ejercicio de tratar de subir por las
escaleras y asignado a un grupo de
bomberos que íbamos a servir
inicialmente hasta el piso 30 y la
cantidad de gente evacuando por las
escaleras no permitió que pudiéramos
cumplir la misión si tus bandos en las
escaleras para ese momento e
inmediatamente salen las noticias que un
segundo avión multe a la torre sur y ya
se empieza a manejar una hipótesis de
acto terrorista
efectivamente para cuando las torres
skype
el caos se apodera de toda la zona pero
la nube que se une a el polvo de la
destrucción de las torres el material
particulado hace diciembre más shows y
efectivamente para cuando ya se
normaliza la situación la estela de ríos
la estela de maldad es que hay unas
calles es la segunda tarde aquí
empezamos a enfrentar para tratar de
recuperar la mayor cantidad de víctimas
se que no podían respirar por ese humo y
por todo lo que yo sé casi nada
louis de igual manera si lo quiere
interrumpir porque no quiero que se
queden por fuera algunas preguntas que
le tengo quería preguntarles en su
carrera como bombero se se había
imaginado ver algo similar además que
fuera más difícil y cómo ve la
recuperación de la ciudad 20 años
después
bueno yo he estado de muchas tragedias
en el mundo haití en mi propio país los
terremotos etcétera pero he denominado
este desastre de esta catástrofe muy
gigante está en un sitio muy pequeño y
eso hizo que cambiara la notación de los
desastres en los que había estado y
desde ese punto de vista en total el en
la devastación que sufrió de nueva york
lo económico en lo humano que dejó ver
claramente
y el deseo de venganza
yo creo que queda plasmado todas las
calles que ha plasmado en todos los
sitios esta devastación
para la fecha de hoy yo creo que no se
ha recuperado ni eeuu ni el mundo se han
podido recuperar de esta tragedia tan
grande entendieron muchas reglas que no
tuvieron que haber muerto
pues lips es duro testimonio gracias por
estar aquí con nosotros en francia